trump supporters descended on mar-a-lago
outraged by the fbi search of his home
della striker who works there said the
place had been violated how did you feel
when he heard it was being searched by
federal agents i feel like
i feel like there's a rape going on walk
to the front place and this place has
been wrecked that 30 fbi people can walk
in
and do that to a man's home when all
they do is call him he would have shown
him and open the safe there was no
comment from donald trump himself though
as he left his new york home recorded
last night saying only this another day
in paradise this was a strange day
the department of justice and the fbi
are also saying nothing about their
unprecedented search of a former
president's home but investigators are
closing in on donald trump a federal
appeals court today ruled he must hand
over his tax records to congress
one senior u.s official has confirmed
that this search was connected with
allegations that donald trump removed
and abused presidential records after
leaving office we won't know what legal
jeopardy that puts him in until we know
what agents found but the political
implications of this are clearer and may
well be in donald trump's favor trump's
acolytes are having a field day
exploiting the fbi's action for maximum
political gain painting him again as the
victim of a politicized department of
justice
i'm
genuinely concerned about what is going
to do to the american society and i
think that a lot of people who might not
find themselves overly political
maybe they didn't even vote for
president trump they're now going to see
this and think that it was just so
disgusting that we're now using our law
enforcement as a weapon some are going
further saying this is the time donald
trump should announce he's running for
president again in the hours after the
raid he issued this video
[Music]
it looked very much like an ad for a new
trump campaign
outside mar-a-lago they urged him to run
should he run again absolutely
absolutely he is going to he's going to
you think he's going to yeah yeah i do
if investigating a former president is
hard enough doing so with the
presidential candidate will be even more
challenging